Oh
okay we're here with Brittany Taylor
how's it going hi amazing yeah yeah well
Kate deals what you have I'm missing the
sash but um we're gonna give me a sash
and I'm the queen of nerds fine so on
your YouTube channel you have like DIY
jewelry clothing but you also have like
music videos yes he also have dance
stuff yes he also have parity stuff yes
I like one dance video one because I my
friend Mike like we're on a dance show
doubt yeah right right you did that
super mario bro yeah I think I just saw
that yeah your channel is really
eclectic there's a ton of stuff going on
can you describe exactly what your
channel is if someone asks I kind of
just do whatever I want so it's like I
kind of like what I feel like that this
week like oh my drawing our picture okay
don't want to make something so i think
it's just like just creative like
anything has to do with like acting or
music or art it's kind of like what it's
just I'm like I'm like I'm like if etsy
was it a channel maybe is that it does
that work I don't know you you just did
that you did it maybe a couple months
ago you did a song for near crush right
yeah the bad yeah draft for near crush
and a rapper hardcore and okay so
there's this idea that right now popular
culture nerds are really popular and
they're really cool were you always a
nerd but growing up yeah our life oh my
gosh I had so little friends growing up
and I was I volunteered the library
during the summer for fun no it was
right down the street from me and I
would like ride my bike back and forth
so yes I have been a nerd since birth is
it frustrating now that like you know
especially on youtube you'll see like a
lot of you know youtubers and people
especially you know young women
youtubers they'll kind of beef o nerdy
they'll be like you know they'll claim
to be nerdy but only to kind of hop on
this popular tight like trend i don't
know i think that like like that's like
the definition of a nerd isn't like
just someone that's being themselves so
I mean is that it's like you're really
seeing who they are so like a lot of
times people will call like let's like
you're already selling moment could be
like oh nerd or whatever so it's like I
don't know I don't think being innards
of bad things even if they're trying
just to figure out who they are more
power to them so in that context what
kind of nerd are you you know you can be
like a technology nerd you could be like
a book like a Selma nerd I love movies
and I'll ever booked an hour to its the
books and films and anything to do with
acting or movies it's like camera
equipment editing it just fell off yes
and that probably led to you being on
YouTube Jesus yeah well I think I was
wives with an infant studio and they ran
out money but when i was there like the
one of the girls just taught me like the
basics on like Final Cut remember taking
like always pages of notes so I learned
editing there but then i bought a green
screen for like 125 bucks and i used to
edit everything on imovie like a film
everything on my webcam so it sounds
like a slow progression with me to like
you need to learn right right you
mentioned that you're kind of a nerd
about books and movies yeah the obvious
desert island question is I try mohabbat
talking about hobbit okay it's coming
out to it's also true that you okay go
ahead what I don't know it's your
interview I should shush Hobbit I have
your to be red but i won't go into NY
yeah every turn that's so weird okay cuz
I interplanar hill and you totally
through be honest love it hell I'm sorry
I'm focused one movie one book desert
island go movie Gladiator book oh gosh I
think it's my problem is like I love the
Harry Potter series and I got really
popular I love the Hunger Games I before
if you got popular probably I'm Marcia
geisha house it Gladia memoirs of a
geisha would be like my to gladiator the
movie the movie yeah the book I don't
know if
there's a book probably there's a Geisha
the book not the movie yes movies pretty
terrible but the movie has its moments
that are really like beautiful like had
some lately cool like life statics but
that doesn't concern at the book no on a
desert island you're watching a lot here
all day every narrows Oh Keesha all day
even two things that are like suicide
cocktails like that is oh no but I think
no more sagacious isn't that sad it has
like I think like no it doesn't mean hi
this moments were like our low or
whatever but it like overall like in the
end you don't want to ruin the book but
it has a good ending you just ruined it
I've never read it he was totally
spoiled it for me and how would your
question how did you get started on
YouTube as a youtuber oh I had I was an
independent studio they ran out of money
came one day they're closed and that's
like right when mullen girl 15 was
blowing up some moms like why don't you
put your videos on youtube version you
know is the cuckoo so I was just pissed
yeah I was by spent six months working
for this company and they just ran out
of money and they just shattered it I
just came one day and there's chains on
the door and it was closed and they
still owe me money you're kidding no I
don't think you're gonna get that money
back it's not it was it was only like 60
bucks it's still like you could have
bought i could have bought memorization
and gladiator and a couple of things in
sixty dollar I'm capped it like an
emergency pack yes just in case someone
else came to the island to like I could
have doubles sharing isn't always great
when you're by yourself like if you only
have two prized possessions on an island
you're not going to want to show her
that's a good point yeah if that one
person could be anyone living or dead
who would it be who you share your
desert island with on the island oh
that's just hard as I would even say
like a hotmail or I love Kate Winslet
though I just want to meet her but I
don't that would be stuck on an island
with her that's really hard but I say
one of my best friends like yeah like
one of like my good friends at least I
you know I have someone I know I like on
the island with me so you can pick like
Abraham Lincoln or Martin Luther King
jr. but I don't know I'm gonna have any
connection to them they could be so
interesting yeah they'll be interesting
for a couple days so I'm gonna be on
there for your whole life like once you
rather be around someone that's like you
know really well and you've known for
years and like
you know that's not at that point yeah
your first option was a hotmail wish
yeah well cuz I like you know like if
you're hot I like in it I don't know
it'd be nice you of course mean like
pieces of mail that have been heated in
the Sun for a long time that's exactly
what i meant talking about yeah it's a
strange choice and it's a controversial
choice but I don't I you know I live on
the edge when it comes to my island
write a piece of post is not a person by
the way just okay just a few letters god
I not a person okay why do you do so
many DIY tutorials on your channel I
think the DIYs are nice and something I
could film myself so I think it's my
schedule so crazy sometimes with
projects outside of YouTube that it's
like yeah i'll have like a day to make
something and not like you know making
the videos that i want to make like
sometimes I need two or three days and
need a day of perhaps a filming day of
editing I need something I can do even
though the end i have spent do [ __ ]
would you go spent hours on them i think
it's just something i can do myself so
if i need to be more simplistic a week I
just want to be by myself and create
then do it what's your favorite project
you've made ooh I probably the last time
I just did what I did like I started
corset like that was awesome and it's
like I just want to wear it everywhere
and like I wish women would go back to
wearing corset there's something like a
sport it just I love it so cool it seems
and I don't know anything about a corset
yes but it seems like it'd be wild and
uncomfortable and two men to the course
I like I think like the old ones where
they lace them and where you can't
breathe yeah but I mean like one's loose
no it's like if anything it just feels
support it kind of like skinny jeans but
on your body right right I think our
viewership is going to be really excited
about this corset talk i think only why
they tuned in to hear about of course
that's is my probably mean it's
interesting no of course what they're
coming back in just like nerds it's true
let it go i don't know that for sure
because you've ever been they just said
nerds are in style you say they were
coming back in they were in a brain in
the first place I don't know about that
was like Ferris Bueller and some of the
old 80's stuff there were some nerds
like like that like not what's the girl
with like sixteen Candles like she's
told on our revenge of the nerds yeah
come on the ferris bueller
his friends are coolest guy in the world
no but one of us like Cameron yeah yeah
he was coupled up say there's like you
know yeah okay it goes in cycles I'll
give you that I'll give you that what
can see that yeah I dredge of endurance
you look like you argued your own point
my own point but you said ferris bueller
that turn it off because he and it means
Ferris Bueller with the movie first
Bueller like sixteen Candles like Molly
Ringwald is like the like I don't make
out like The Breakfast Club all the
misfit he's a nerd in it oh it was just
a captain crunch did you put the pixie
stix when she goes to bite into this now
much like I know I know in movies I got
you okay I'll concede that point okay
match point after from five years ago
how have you seen you to change uh
changes it feels like it changes every
day oh oh my god the homepage used to be
you or like they would care ate it and
you could actually email the editor and
try to get your videos and like whatever
video was on there would be guaranteed
thank a million or something views and
it would be like and I was like 16 or 20
like on the homepage they're constantly
updating and then on each category page
there's a video at the top that would be
like there was a called spotlight it
would spotlight videos so I mean and
then just even the brat like then it
switches like a browse page was like a
grid for you and it wasn't all these
categories there's money all the most
power for their views for like videos
for in a browse page and then the
homepage switched to three videos early
category on the homepage to where it is
now worth a gazillion categories a
zillion videos in each category so with
the brand new update their kind of
focusing on what you recommended for you
videos you know it's like what you want
to watch videos what do you think about
that updated I think it's I think it
just as a slight grows interested it
it's making it a little harder for
people to like fine stuff I think
because there's so much information but
that's not just really important to like
keep a consistent like upload schedule
because they're also you might get lost
in the mix because like YouTube is
throwing so much information that you
like in your subscription box they're
curing that unless you click like the
uploads only so like it makes it harder
and harder to find stuff you're actually
subscribed to and a lot of people argue
that that you know this idea that's
making hard things hard to find YouTube
is focusing more on engagement so they
want people to go to your channel and
stay on there for an
city dancing around in different
channels and subscribing because now
they've noticed they people watch like
forty percent more videos or whatever
when they are subscribed to a channel
because they get invested in that person
in their life right does that make you
simic you change how you upload videos
at all that YouTube's focusing more on
engagement no because I things like like
I all I can do is what I already do and
I'm lucky you might she might change
like how long your annotations are or
like you know what you know you might if
you're gonna make a 10 minute video you
made better make sure there's no leg so
people don't click off like you're
trying to get people to watch till the
end hopefully they'll like it but um no
I think for me I've always just kind of
done my own thing so and then it's kind
of work for me so you were just on dance
show what was that like because I'll be
honest I the idea of dancing to me is
the fate worse than death I always
wanted to do it and I think I was want
me to get a really good dance partner
that like we're friends in life now
because then we can't spend that many
hours of someone and you either like you
honestly either make a Bonnie like each
other you don't but you can't like spend
16 hours rehearsing like two different
times so it's like over 30 hours
together just in our heart like dancing
and not like you know you either get
along are you don't write so but you
like never once got frustrated or angry
with me or and I think I don't think
people realize how hard it was for every
contestant to do this because we're only
given a certain amount of time like will
give an eight hour rehearsal day we have
a day off and then we perform it the
next day I mean the we know parts on our
own time or whatever it's up to our
partners if we have like other
rehearsals but it's it's crazy yeah it
seems pretty crazy and I mean I see it
it makes me just dance showdown in
general it makes me uncomfortable
because I kind of can't imagine
like I've always always wanted to do it
though did you dance freebies to it no I
mean I took some ballet classes when I
was younger but it was like really we
just never had any good dance studio
it's like they're really bad I was like
five so I've always grown up loving
dance movies like you know center stage
and Flashdance and dirty dancing and I
can go on and on like those like I
member ID my parents drove me the 45
minutes to go see center stage was it
wasn't playing in our town so like I've
always grown up line dance stuff what
about dirty dancing to Havana I didn't
like you know like that okay I like I'll
just step up once and the cheesy I liked
trying to think what other no I'm just
like I I like yeah or like what was on
with a Julia Stiles uh-oh take the last
night yes why oh that just like that's
all is one of those miracle things
usually because when someone doesn't
know something then like deliverance I
Katya was their name oh crap oh crap
yeah your YouTube channel website
Twitter are like flooded with rainbows
and unicorns and sparkles and glitter as
I was researching this I found so much
of that can you explain why that's
happening um like my audience the 83%
female and we're all like I'm just I
think it just shows everything I like on
one page like why not just throw it out
there like this is me like I'm loud I
like funky things anything sparkly I
have to have it like I think it's just
the best way it's like that's just me
like you know right away what my
personality is like like I'm not all
black with like skulls and crossbones
like that's great if that's what you're
into but like I buy shirts to skull and
crossbones on them but like I'm my page
it's all the attention happiness and
this is it a lot of happiness well sure
you do a kind of a beauty channel to
give a beauty challenge direct yes I
started that not too long ago so on are
things for like six months or right why
did you want to start of each other
because YouTube it seems really
oversaturated beauty channels but i
think my my beauty videos are way
different than a lot of the beauty gurus
this is like minor like
I think I could bring one thing I could
bring its production quality it's I get
my like my friend James two films i get
really beautiful shots and I don't make
them 20 minutes long i'm not one of
people that like is gifted that people
will watch for 20 minutes while i talk
about my hair whatever they some of the
girls can and they're very interesting i
don't know how they do it but like for
me like i just wanted to make a place
it's like people like either in out
quick like they want information they
want something really cool and it's I
feel like they can go do it to write
like all these DIYs they're so
long-winded that people like get a
little overwhelmed because they're like
oh my god I 10 minutes and they'll tell
me how to do this in 20 minutes and they
totally do that like me in two or three
minutes explain to you how to do it and
these car will start sending me pics
like that day like Luke I wouldn't go to
the wire like I just said this heart
ring one I have a zillion types of
people that sent me that they've already
made them that's pretty cool what new
DIY tutorials can people expect for your
channel I have let's see the ones I
bought one film right now it's just
really cool it's using like it's not the
kind of like crap yarn but you create
these really cool rap prices of buttons
so I've been trying to do a lot of stuff
that people could make for Christmas for
their friends that would not going to
cost them barely anything to make so I
have that one coming out and then from
there I'll just probably like go into my
bag of tricks and see that I've done too
much jewelry stuff so i should do you
know sometimes for your hair for
clothing or something could give your
shoes to be cool or whatever they do to
my shoes of people yeah like my brother
my brother it was so funny like you saw
my studded or it showed people had to
tie instead like like shoes for converse
my brother literally over thanksgiving
made a pair and they're so freaking cool
like his analytical brain like worked
out the pattern ahead of time and
created this is really cool as geometric
shapes with all these different little
studs and freakin awesome it's pretty
cool yeah anyways I'm like Blue Fame to
green and their surf awesome so my last
question is yeah you said you have like
a eighty-three percent female audience
yeah young empowered smart he's not
beautiful like it's really cool girls
the whole game it real yes if you give
one piece of advice right now what would
that be the device being I think it's
just literally it's gonna sound cliche
but I mean it like figure out what you
love in life whatever
dreama's and don't stop push you're
never gonna be happy if you don't you
will always think that you sacrificed
like getting married or having kids for
your dream like don't no matter how hard
things get don't quit because you could
be like one yes away even though you've
collected a million knows there we go
that's it well done thank you for
talking to me we've done it thank you
for watching my interview on noumea
rockstars calm and if you want to check
out my channel go to youtube com for
Sasha Brita Louise de there ok good no
seriously go away I was kidding
seriously I'm just joking but really ok